well let's let's talk about what's going
on here in washington county so for
those that aren't familiar
um we are in western maryland and uh
we're uh i live in west virginia
officially but we work out of western
maryland and i i don't think we'll be
doing that much longer because i think
that the policies of this state are
insane and what you often see is
leftists not understanding how taxes
work
not understanding how businesses work
we just actually is a really great tweet
david hogg you know the guy from
parkland
yes you see this tweet he said no i
tweeted it's very funny it's too
difficult to form an llc this is
ridiculous there's too many regulations
and people were like accidental
conservative moment no it's a young kid
who did not realize how difficult it is
often now when you get older you get
experience it's actually relatively easy
but i'll tell you the challenges
the first formation of a company i did
was confusing and very difficult because
we didn't imagine someone walks up to
you and they hand you five bowling pins
and say juggle
you'll be like okay okay i can't do that
and i'm like figure it out take you a
long time to figure it out once you get
the hang of it you can mix it up and
you're juggling like i know how to do
this yeah where i'm at now with this
company it's really easy to start
companies and and work with it but i
have a team we have accountants we have
lawyers for a regular person it's so
difficult and so what we end up seeing
with many other people on the left is
they don't start companies so they have
no idea what's going on no they go to
government and then the government
passes laws like how do we increase tax
revenue i know increase taxes well i'll
tell you what the result of that is
we're leaving yeah we're moving our
headquarters over we've been building
freedom stand for a few months we
already have many employees who are
already
reporting out of there and we're going
to move everything to west virginia
because we're 10 minutes away because
it's almost heaven yeah yes yeah is that
is that the slogan or something like
john denver
okay
but no i think it's funny every time
someone on the left tries to do
something even remotely productive they
end up dropping some kind of
conservative take about it he's like
yeah man it's really hard to start this
company it's like oh my god i actually
did something in the real world
now he has a conservative opinion how
interesting this is interesting um jen
perlman who we've had on the show
who is a progressive democrat
was tweeting about billionaires paying
their fair share
and i said how much do you think is fair
is 55 a fair share and jen responded
that
perhaps
25 to 30 percent if you get rid of the
loopholes was a fair share and so i said
are you saying you would want to reduce
the tax burden on billionaires if you
could close the loopholes and they said
yeah i think so and i'm like
i don't know if i agree with that
completely but that's an interesting
take uh i also wonder if they really
understand what loopholes mean
i don't think they do no because i don't
think they would be arguing for that if
they understood what the tech loop tax
loophole really was well a lot of the
tax loopholes what they call loopholes
are built in to incentivize businesses
investors entrepreneurs to do things
that the government wants them to do to
get them involved in economic zones in
underprivileged areas
low-income areas
it's about trying to bring in
high-tech businesses and give them a tax
break
in an area like washington county so you
get high-tech companies coming in
instead of low-paying
uh warehouse jobs why would they call
that a loophole and not a tax break
incentive
because they don't actually want people
to be incentivized to do good things i
just want to punish anyone who's more
successful than that no it's because
look i think most of them never never
ran a business yep they don't pay
business taxes
in their mind they were told evil
billionaires aren't paying their fair
share yes the problem i have with that
is i'm like look i'm with steve with
with bannon on this one tax the rich
however i don't think giving the
government like
the idea
in and of itself but
government's not going to do a good job
with it so i don't know how i ultimately
feel with the end results of that but
the issue is
they don't actually have a definition of
what fair means yeah fair share rhymes
it's catchy it's a rhetoric meaningless
thing that's why i said it's 55 percent
fair you're not going to get a straight
fair welcome to earth dude fairness come
on but when you look at say the income
tax 50 percent of people
that
earn income do not pay an income tax
right and the top one percent pay a
tremendo i don't know what the number is
but it's overwhelming amount so if you
actually break down the tax burden
um by bracket
most people
receive more benefits from taxes than
they pay into it most people even up to
like 100 or 200k per year it's only
around or after that people start
actually paying taxes and it's the
overwhelmingly the one percent and the
billionaires who are paying the taxes
that fund the benefits for all of the
poor i like i like that i have no
problem with that that's i have a
problem with with the government being
unaccountable with being bloated and
corrupt the idea that rich people or you
know we pay a percentage in taxes and
that goes to helping poor people have
cleaner water or roads i like it you
know we're only as strong as our weakest
link but we don't have that
we've got a broken tax system we've got
leftists who don't understand it who are
being manipulated then impose tax laws
which hurt their own states and we have
bloated government that siphons money
off for bs reasons we have like gender
package pakistani gender studies
corporations that are considered
multinational that bounce from country
to country depending on the tax levels
they have bank accounts in panama the
panama papers breaks and shows all these
people have like they're hoarding their
wealth offshores this is the real life
reality so how do you deal with that
corporations aren't going to sit around
and pay you exorbitant taxes they're
just going to move their money can i
give you an example i've been
campaigning and i've been going door to
door i'm trying to hit 200 to 250 homes
every day
talking to people that are paying taxes
older people in their homes younger
people just getting started with young
kids
and in washington county
we have a tremendous surplus the amount
might be 40 50 million dollars in excess
revenue
they're talking about a three million
dollar property tax cut for the whole
county that will amount to about fifty
dollars for an average family making
fifty thousand dollars a year living in
a moderate priced home about a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars fifty 50
total rebate
the assessments in in this county
we get reassessed one-third of the
houses get reassessed every year
the assessments are going up so it's
going to be almost 100 a month more
for that average house so we're giving
fifty dollars back but we're taking
eleven hundred and fifty dollars
from them
that's driving elder people out of their
homes they're part of the fabric of the
community we want the grandparents and
the elderly to be there because they're
part of that community they're important
but they're having to leave for west
virginia for pennsylvania or go to
florida so maryland is a ridiculous
state
and the taxes are so insane west
virginia is literally you know a hand
we could drive a half an hour and we're
at our new uh headquarters
is that half an hour drive
is it worth losing
hundreds of thousands to millions of
dollars that well that's ridiculous
so maryland
it doesn't seem to understand that you
know i understand maybe for like a brick
and mortar business but the nature of
our business and the growth we're having
we have no choice but to leave the state
and that means maryland will end up
losing tax revenue instead of just
saying we will compete for your business
with with west virginia you could have
something where like certain areas of
maryland have a tax certain tax rate but
the further west you go it starts to go
down so it becomes a little more like
the neighboring states they do the
opposite they they increase so uh the
way it works is
if you're a resident of west virginia
and you work in maryland they charge you
an additional tax wow instead of saying
thank you for bringing your business
here they say we're going to punish you
for bringing your business here yeah
well and people don't really understand
that this is a matter of incentives like
you said that that's what it is it's a
punishment of course no nothings look at
that and go hey they're raising money
for our budget i've discussed and broken
down the laffer curve on this show
before a lot of lefties
who don't know anything about economics
which is to say most lefties will
actually tell you the laffer curve
doesn't exist that's not true no
left-wing economist even says that the
disagreement is just over where the
parabola peaks conservative leading
economists tend to say it's somewhere
near 20 left-wing economists might say
as high as 70 percent if they're really
crazy but ultimately people are not
going to work for money when they can't
keep as much of it it's really basic
stuff
i just think it's
a tremendous oversight
for there to be a tri-state area between
virginia maryland west virginia
and maryland's like we're going to make
it more expensive so everyone's like why
would i be in maryland well it's similar
to illinois illinois is surrounded by
red states
lower taxes higher productive
productivity more economic growth and
illinois is losing population the taxes
go up because the more people that leave
the more the producers leave the more
those left behind have to pay to support
the gargantuan government apparatus
that's in place grassroots atlas
shrugged well you know we see evidence
of this kind of thing in the real world
too so despite all of the lies the media
said to convince people otherwise after
the trump tax cuts we saw a revenue
increase our deficit increased as well
because increased spending outpaced the
increase in revenue but the left used
the fact that the deficit increased to
argue
that we lost revenue it actually wasn't
the case they were just lying about it
but when you tax people less they have
more incentive to work and they generate
more wealth for the economy and then
take a look it's not just your income
tax it's not just your property tax
it's the higher gasoline
tax it's the higher sales tax it's the
fees that they pass on on cable directv
the water costs more all these things
are passed on okay
more so here than in west virginia
well and they know this it's interesting
they know this because when it comes to
taxing cigarettes or alcohol or even
gasoline it's understood that there's an
agenda there and the agenda is we want
people to use less of this so they're
willing to recognize when it's
convenient for them that when you
increase taxes on something you end up
with a less productive market there
you're not able to sell as much of it
and yet when it comes to human labor
they're completely blind to it you know
what else is interesting this crypto
stuff uh they didn't start taxing it
till like 2018 i think uh and so
basically there's like another 700
billion dollars in the economy that
maybe isn't accounted for right now that
untaxed just wealth was just created out
of nothing so that's true considering uh
the mass printing of money
the explosion in the money supply i'm
not sure if 700 billion dollars has puts
a dent in it yeah right it's up to two
two trillion and crypto
there abouts you see fluctuates west
virginia's got constitutional carry
there you go it's it's just
western maryland
i guess the way the states have
structured themselves they can't
adapt properly fast enough i don't know
it just seems ridiculous to me that the
current system is too sluggish to
realize
the western maryland system they're
going to be losing
prominent industry why did they not make
it so you could pay taxes online when
you were at the white house i don't know
if you were involved with the economic
stuff at all but like it's an act of
congress like why would they not focus
on streamlining that process so you can
go and click a few buttons have your
payment go direct from your bank account
instead they make you like file all this
paperwork and search for things and go
to this and then they can't and then
it's like i got to pay them well that's
that's that's that's like 21st century
talking about their incompetence and
sluggishness
this is lobbying there's big companies
that make billions of dollars off of tax
filing preparation well here here's the
question i have for you i i took two
months with facebook to try and get
validated to have a campaign page it
took me two months and they even used
snail mail in the process which slowed
the pro the whole thing down i sold my
house from the time i called the
internet company open door
until i got a check in the mail it took
me 13 days i never saw a person yet
facebook a modern company
two months to validate me as a person to
be able to run political ads
yep bureaucracy so
is it this is too big the american
government has too many people working
there
yes nothing ever gets smaller no
programs ever die nope
exactly that's a float now they gotta
know that if if you hang on to a dying
system and you refuse to shut shred it
apart it's gonna get overthrown like
that's the inevitable if you look at
history from but thousands and thousands
of years in the past that's what happens
with societies if you were refused to
reform but what happens is
as the culture starts to decay and break
down
many people recognize we need a reform
or it's going to fall apart and once
that happens people say well i can't
count on you so i better grab as much
silverware as possible as the ship sinks
and that's the thing and then what's
happening right now we've gone through
things like reinventing government okay
that was a big thing i think in in the
clinton years we had george bush
reinvent and redesign the whole
intelligence community 16 agencies and
develop the defense i mean the
department of national intelligence it
didn't solve anything really it just
created another layer of bureaucracy
more jobs
more elite
but it's not any better did you guys
consider defaulting on the interest of
the federal reserve i wasn't involved in
that that would have been mr minchin and
you know others so thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you